[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le retard à l'allumage de la
campagne française de vaccination fait
scandale on accuse pêle-mêle le
président de la république le
gouvernement la bureaucratie la
logistique les anti vaccins ou le manque
de 12 d'être responsable du fait qu'au
1er janvier la france avait vacciné que
332 personnes contre 6000 en autriche
soit 20 fois plus
onze mille en roumanie 47000 en pologne
plus de 131000 en allemagne trois cent
trente fois plus
depuis ça s'est un peu accéléré on en
est à sept mille personnes ayant reçu au
moins une dose de vaccin soit 0,00 0 1%
de la population un dix millième de la
population française
l'objectif étant d'arriver à 60% de
cette même population
pour espérer mettre fin à l'épidémie
alors y at il un problème est quelle en
est la cause pour en débattre nous avons
invité aurélie haroche rédactrice en
chef au journal international de
médecine jim point fr sur internet
leader de l'information médicale
francophone qui existe depuis 1979 quand
vous expliquer on va pas dire tout ce
bordel mais on va dire veut dire un mot
plus gentils comme ang son retard à
l'allumage on va dire je pense qu'il ya
un mélange de peur il ya la peur de la
réaction des médecins libéraux s'est il
avait été trop écartés de la campagne il
y à la peur de la défiance vaccinale et
il ya la peur de la pénurie il a peur
que si trop de personnes voulaient se
faire vacciner d'un coup il n'est pas pu
gérer la pénurie de doses
je pense que ces trois a peur et puis
aussi il ya eu ils n'ont pas envisagé
que l'allemagne allait commencer aussi
vite
et la comparaison avec l'allemagne a été
insupportable c'est ça qui est le plus
parce que c'est ça le déclic alors c'est
ça qui ont fait bien accéléré oui je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'on a accéléré
parce que l'objectif c'était de
commencer 30 le 18 janvier donc au début
de faire quelque chose de cosmétiques le
symbolique vacciner un petit peu et le
18 janvier tout est prêt mais quand on a
vu que les autres pays avaient commencé
beaucoup plus vite c'est ça qui a créé
françois krakowski
et vous vous êtes médecin expert en
politiques publiques de santé adhérents
de la république en marche devait
participer la taskforce santé du
candidat macron lors de l'élection
présidentielle alors se rate à l'arrêt
ce retard à l'allumage vous vous
l'expliquez comment je sais pas c est
vraiment un retard puisque au final
c'est les chiffres ils sont cohérents
avec la stratégie qui est qui et qui est
mise en oeuvre après c'est vrai que ça
paraît un peu lent quand même hein je
suis pas sûr que je suis pas sûr que
mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
forcément le gouvernement qu'ils soient
avisés je ne dis pas ça par amitié
quelconque armé par pragmatisme c'est
que à chaque fois qu'on met en oeuvre
quelque chose en france depuis plusieurs
années
ça met toujours beaucoup de temps c'est
toujours compliqué et c'est souvent en
fait en lien avec un manque de confiance
et un souhait de contrôler beaucoup de
choses qui dit qui fait rajouter des
couches des vérifications des des
contrôles eu beaucoup de bureaucratie et
c'est peut-être notre système
administratif et institutionnel qui est
avisé puisque nos stratégies et est
nouveau et nos professionnels nos
acteurs qui assurent généralement jean
françois corty médecin vous allez
travailler dans l'humanitaire vous avez
été directeur des opérations
internationales pour médecins du monde
une organisation non gouvernementale qui
a l'habitude de mettre en place des
campagnes de vaccination en période de
crise alors là et ils auraient dû
prendre des leçons peut-être c'est sûr
que j'aurais pu s'inspirer d'une
expérience des humanitaires on va dire
french doctor qui depuis près de plus de
50 ans vaccinés avec des autorités
locales dans les conditions difficiles
ce qui est clair c'est que on voit bien
qu'il ya beaucoup d'incertitude lié
évidemment l'expression du virus fait
qu'ils évoluent qui est des mutants des
incertitudes aussi au niveau des
stratégies et vaccinales et on voit bien
la nécessité
voir réajuster régulièrement des
stratégies qui ne sont jamais totalement
certaine le gouvernement a fait le choix
de prioriser sur différents principes
éviter des morts dé saturer les hôpitaux
faire en sorte que les services
essentiels fonctionnent mais il a oublié
un facteur humain déterminante qui est
le temps me pouvoir avoir des
consentements bref créer des conditions
au fond on a peu de gens vaccinés avec
des vaccins qui se retrouve pourtant
présent dans des congélateurs donc le
besoin aussi pour ce gouvernement
d'assumer qu'une démocratie sanitaire
doit être plus proactive être davantage
à l'écouté aussi des gens de terrain
pour pouvoir réajuster régulièrement en
dynamique des stratégies qui méritent
d'être discutées et rediscuté
régulièrement marie marie c'est un
pseudo vous êtes membre des vaccins un
collectif militant qui existe depuis
trois ans incluant des professionnels de
santé
un collectif qui lutte contre la
désinformation concernant les maths les
vaccins notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux où vous faites beaucoup parlé de
vous vous souhaitez conserver votre
anonymat car certains membres des
vaccins ont déjà reçu des menaces de
mort
ça ne vous empêche pas évidemment de
vous exprimer alors qu'est-ce qui n'a
pas marché alors déjà je veux refaire un
point il n'y a pas de membres parmi nous
qui soit dans le médical
oui nous n'avons pas de médecin chef et
vexe ensuite nous ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que depuis quelques années la
parole était énormément donné aux
antilles vax on a un problème en france
de défiance envers la vaccination qui
remonte à la campagne de vaccination
massive contre l'hépatite b qui a été
accusé à tort de causer la sclérose en
plaques et il ya eu aussi le précédent
h1n1 qui a fait beaucoup pour la
défiance il ya eu beaucoup de critiques
à ce moment là et je pense
qu'effectivement depuis le gouvernement
marche un peu sur des
concernant la vaccination alors
justement on a beaucoup dit en fait
toute cette stratégie très lente avec
beaucoup de précaution est dû au très
grand nombre d'anti vagues ce qui existe
en france il serait même la majorité
alors est-ce que ça peut être une des
explications
et après tout il va falloir faire avec
pendant toute la campagne de vaccination
il va y avoir des gens qui ne veulent
pas se faire vacciner
mais est-ce que ça a pu présider un
certain nombre de décisions qui ont été
prises
et qui font qu'on en est là où on en est
aujourd'hui on les lit à roche oui je
pense que ça a forcément joué il avait
peur que le mouvement anti vaccin est
trop d'importance après en plus cela
c'est qu'ils jouent mais en plus c'est
qu'on est face à des vaccins nouveaux ou
des vaccins qui n'ont jamais été
utilisés et donc ça peut évidemment
renforcé les craintes et en plus sur
sept et mité minnelli il ya eu tellement
de théories complotistes et c'est que
les gens pouvaient tirer ou est-ce que
c'est pas si grave on n'a pas besoin de
se vacciner donc j'avais vraiment
beaucoup de choses
apotex qui est vraiment très lourd
importés et que le gouvernement a
affronté pendant un an et sans doute il
avait envie que ce soit quelque chose de
tranquille et c'est donc et puis en plus
le gouvernement d'autant je pense qu'il
y avait quand même aussi une certaine
forme de sincérité le gouvernement n'a
pas voulu donner l'impression qu'il
allait forcer les gens à vacciner et
être sérieux même été un peu trop fort
parce que avec ce consentement très faim
qu'ils ont voulu mettre en place et
voilà ça a été ça a été presque
contre-productif et on avait presque
l'impression que même ne croyez pas
vraiment au rex il y avait un manque de
d'entousiasme dollars par eux mêmes
soient remplies oui bah je partage
vraiment ce qu'il ya ce qui a été dit
c'est je pense que les toutes les
mesures liées au consentement à la
consultation préalable c'était en effet
pour donner cette impression ont fait en
tout cas montré qu'il y avait une
volonté de vraiment prendre en compte la
volonté de chacun sur ses vaccinations
maintenant ce qui est un peu dommage
c'est que dans une dans une situation de
crise comme celle là où on doit aller on
doit aller quand même assez vite parce
que c'est la vaccination il faut le dire
c'est la seule solution aujourd'hui pour
sortir à moyen terme de cette crise de
cette épidémie on aurait pu simplifier
après je sais pas si c'est vraiment le
gouvernement qui met toutes ses règles
et ses mesures de ce que j'ai connu
souvent c'est qu'il ya un moulinage des
propositions la stratégie du
gouvernement par voie différente on en
parle souvent des nombreuses agences
titution des directions d administration
qui l ont vocation plutôt à la contrôler
à réduire les risques et du coup ajoute
tout c'est toutes ces étapes et c'est
vrai que c'est dommage parce que
finalement ça montre encore un peu un
manque de confiance vers les acteurs
c'est à dire on a un peu l'impression
d'objets de faire une consultation avant
la vaccination auprès d'un médecin
traitant
on perd du temps 1 à une personne qui a
envie de se faire vacciner
c'est juste une étape en plus ce qui est
inutile pour elle puisque de toute façon
elle va dire d'accord vacciner mois donc
elle va devoir consulter ensuite l'atl à
l'information aux devoirs transité par
forcément l'assurance maladie ou pour
montrer que l'accord a été donné la
consultation réalisée pour débloquer
l'accès au vaccin et ensuite seulement
on croit à vacciner le consentement
recuites c'est donc en fait encore on
monte un peu une machine à gaz mais je
pense pas qu'elle soit souhaitait
lorsque des quand on écoute olivier
ferrand il a plutôt envie d'accélérer
les choses
je pense que il ya encore une fois et
comme souvent dans la mise en oeuvre la
mise en oeuvre un j'assiste de politique
publique en santé
des retards et des longueurs mais qui
sont pas le fait du souhait politique ou
du souhait du gouvernement et encore
moins des acteurs mais plutôt d'une
d'une usine à gaz qui est construite
pour pouvoir s'assurer du contrôle de
plein d'éléments donc encore une fois un
manque de confiance auprès des acteurs
on pourrait tout à fait imaginer dans
les ehpad 1 qui est un médecin ou une
infirmière et j'élargis pharmaciens
professionnels de santé quels qu'ils
soient qui comme tout soit recueil le
consentement éclairé du patient tout
simplement avant l'injection et pouvoir
la pratiquer tout de suite pourquoi
rajouter une consultation à grands pas
et si éventuellement leurs patients un
citoyen c'est pas forcément impatient
d'ailleurs un doute dans ce cas là
l'orienter pour pouvoir apporter une
explication ou pas ou s'il veut
absolument pas eh bah c'est son choix
on est dans un pays libre et dans ce cas
peut-être qu'un jour il changera d'avis
et on gagnerait du temps je pense qu'on
se rajoutent des choses pour ce pour se
conforter et puis pour éliminer duris
par précaution une précaution qui est
trop forte je pense l'entrepris caution
trop de bureaucratie
on l'a beaucoup pourtant dû cette année
tendent notamment au gouvernement
d'ailleurs pour se défendre pour dire
c'est pas nous c'est les autres
vous en pensez-quoi jean françois corty
je pense que le gouvernement par part de
loin concernant la question de la
confiance qui est un invariant
immatériel fondamental pour pouvoir
gérer une épisode un épisode de crise
sanitaire aussi marquant avec la
médecine de catastrophe aux quotidiens à
gérer beaucoup de morts un nombre de
patients conséquent sur un temps court
avec une thérapeutique qui a certes
évolué mais qui a encore insuffisante on
ne guérit pas avec des traitements
aujourd'hui et puis un vaccin on voit
qu'ils arrivent très progressivement
donc le gouvernement part de loin en
terme de confiance
on l'a vu mise à l'épreuve avec une
communication relativement foireuse lors
des épisodes autour des masques et des
tests on est dans un contexte aussi où
il ya des incertitudes sur le vaccin
les vaccins qui arrive que ce soit le
green tech ou demain moderna et
prochainement astrazeneca
on n'a pas énormément de recul
aujourd'hui pour s'assurer d'une limite
maximum des effets secondaires ceci dit
ça représente un véritable espoir
évidemment je recommande de se faire
vacciner le plus rapidement possible
parce que ce sera possible mais on ne
sait pas encore par exemple si ce vaccin
qui va certes limiter l'évolution des
formes graves a limité l'extension de
l'épidémie notamment même si certains
articles commencent à sortir pour dire
qu'effectivement ces vaccins limiteront
potentiellement les transmissions
même chez les patients qui seront
asymptomatiques ou qui seront qui n'en
prend pas de forme grave en bref que le
vaccin pourra limiter l'épidémie et puis
aussi on est dans un contexte où il ya
un manque de transparence évident et une
incapacité depuis de nombreuses années
de l'état à pouvoir notamment
informer sur les négociations avec les
laboratoires qui pour certains se gavent
en mettant parfois en tension des
systèmes de santé solidaire y compris
les pays riches on a vu ça lors de la
sortie du traitement contre l'hépatite c
il ya quelques années vendu 50 mille
euros le traitement alors qu'en coûts de
production édité à 100 euros
on a bien vu les difficultés d'un état à
pouvoir faire face à des laboratoires
être en difficulté pour pouvoir imposer
la défense de l'intérêt général et donc
de fait cela ce manque de transparence
encore aujourd'hui qu'on ne sait pas
dans quelles conditions se sont passées
les négociations autour des prix que ce
soit en france évidemment à l'échelle
européenne qui peuvent renforcer les
positionnements de postures complotistes
donc les autorités partent de loin dans
un contexte où évidemment les mortalités
reste importante où il ya une
priorisation encore une fois comme je
disais tout à l'heure pour limiter les
mortalités cela peut se comprendre mais
probablement une défaillance notamment
en termes de capacités logistiques à
pouvoir tenir compte des exigences du
vaccin actuel mise en congélateur à près
de 80 moins 80 une incapacité à pouvoir
être à développer plus de moyens sur le
terrain et donc se retrouver dans une
situation où on est un petit peu à la
traîne par rapport aux autres européens
européen sur sûr
le déroulement de cette campagne de
vaccination qui va s'accentuer de
manière exponentielle mais qui
aujourd'hui en terme de communication
par rapport aux autres pays européens
mais le gouvernement dans une très
grande difficulté marie des vaccins oui
donc marque par rapport au oui non je
vous écoute donc moi je voulais revenir
sur cette histoire de consentement qui
est demandé et sert à ça a été fait pour
donner confiance aux gens or si vous
écoutez si vous allez sur les pages
anti-vaccins cetera
ça leur donne pas plus confiance que si
on avait payé pour d'obligatoire parce
que pour eux si on demande le
consentement c'est forcément quelque
part derrière c'est dangereux et qu' il
va y avoir des effets secondaires
terrible et que c'est pour ça qu'on
demande à signer avant pour se dégager
de toute responsabilité en cas de pépin
donc quelle que soit la manière dont on
va prendre les choses d'un côté ou de
l'autre
il y aura toujours un look quelque part
tour ces gens là donc en fait je vous
dit fait que le gouvernement et s'est
mis lui même en otage auprès des anti
vaccins et qu'au fond on a tout à y
perdre un problème de son là oui on vous
entend plus marion va tâcher de régler
ça vous avez assisté sur la logistique
on l'a mise souvent en accusation elle
aussi ce serait la logistique qui
n'auraient pas suivi
alors soit c'est la bureaucratie soit
c'est la logistique vous avez remarqué
quelque chose aurélia roche du côté de
la logistique
ce qui est sûr c'est que en voulant
faire une vaccination dans les ehpad
on s'est mis un frein logistiques
supplémentaires puisque comme c'est un
vaccin difficile à manipuler
c'était compliqué et d'ailleurs la
question des cinq jours dont on a
beaucoup parlé c'était pas un délai de
rétractation c'était pour pouvoir avoir
le temps de commander les vaccins qu'ils
arrivent au bon moment et que tout soit
prêt le jour où les vaccins sont là donc
que les consultations soit faite et
c'est donc
forcément la logistique était était
complexe
on aurait à mon avis c'était pas du tout
insurmontable mais il fallait mettre en
place des équipes mobiles il fallait
faire quelque chose qu'on pouvait
l'imaginer mais ça j'ai pas l'impression
que enfin je pense qu'ils avaient
anticipé que ça serait difficile mais il
n'avait pas anticipé qu'on allait les
presser autant et probablement avoir des
vaccinodromes comme on dit ou des
centres de vaccination ça facilite
énormément mais le gouvernement s'y est
refusée longtemps parce qu'il ne voulait
pas reproduire la situation de la grippe
h5n1 parce que les médecins généralistes
s'était senti vraiment lésés à ce moment
là mais je pense que on n'est pas du
tout le même contexte parce qu'on est
dans une épidémie beaucoup beaucoup plus
grave et là les gens ou envie de se
faire vacciner parce que ils ont peur
donc voilà et ensuite sur les anti
vaccins juste je pense qu'on exagère
leur pouvoir parce qu'en réalité il ya
que vit pour ce sont les français qui
sont vraiment des anti vaccins pur et
dur et qui ne veulent jamais vacciner si
on avait eu pendant tout le mois de
décembre une campagne d'explication peut
être qu'on aurait pu faire baisser la
tendance
parce que dans notre pays contrairement
aux autres pays la défiance vis-à-vis du
vaccin comme i d'augmenter alors que
dans les autres pays allait diminuer
married et des vaccins et les est de
retour non là pas l'air de m'entendre
françois crabe en skiff
oui c'est très intéressant cette
question de logistique et de et de mise
en oeuvre
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure en
france je pense qu'on est plutôt bon
pour ce qui est stratégique ouvrant en
termes de santé parce qu'on a des
institutions qui sont qu'ils sont
capables de faire des bonnes analyses et
de faire des bonnes stratégies alors
qu'est ce que c'est quoi une stratégie
déjà parce que vous savez on peut se
demander bouchaud s'est fixé des
objectifs des objectifs qui sont
pertinents au regard d'une situation
d'un état des lieux et de fixer les
grandes orientations pour répondre à ces
objectifs
et là je pense qu'il ya un rappel
intéressant à faire
en tout cas j'ai une question c'est pour
vous aujourd'hui c'est quoi l'objectif
en rapport avec l'épidémie l'objectif
tout le monde dit que c'est de vacciner
60 % de la population
alors est ce que c'est le 4 pour moi
l'objectif principal c'est empêcher des
morts je prends et c'est ce qu'on essaie
objectif qui est poursuivie en fait
depuis le depuis le début de la crise on
a dit on n'accomplit pas d'empêcher les
gens de forcément toujours de contracter
la maladie
ce qu'on veut empêcher on l'avant sinon
je fais un petit rappel c'est ed aplanir
la courbe
la quoi et pourquoi on voulait aplanir
c'est pour éviter que les services dans
les hôpitaux notamment sos de
réanimation soient dépassées et de ne
plus contrôler la létalité du de pardon
de l'infection donc on est toujours là
et c'est pour cela qu'il ya une cible
aujourd'hui des plus de 65 ans des
personnes fragiles alors qu'ils évoluent
puisqu'on voit con mais c'est
d'accélérer les choses parce que il ya
neuf personnes sur dix de plus de 65 ans
qui décèdent ciel assis à la trappe
locaux vides
donc c'est logique et cohérent on les
ciblent en priorité on fixe une priorité
parce qu'on n'a pas un membre de doses
infinie donc on se dit si on vise en
premier ceux qui ont le plus gros taux
de létalité bah finalement on répond à
notre objectif premier qui est de
limiter les morts puisque chez les plus
jeunes on peut avoir des jets vécu
l'expérience par des formes qui sont
très peu symptomatiques
donc on a je pense qu'on a un bon
objectif
on a des bonnes orientations première
dans la stratégie et après dans la mise
en oeuvre et ben on bloque alors soit
pour des raisons logistiques soit voilà
pour des raisons administratives remet
des règles on machines des usines à gaz
etc pour s'assurer que tout est bien
fait ou comme l'a dit très justement
tout à l'heure on en crée défiance à
vouloir rajouter des étapes de dire de
d'accord de consentement plutôt que d'y
aller dire c'est bon on y va regarder
voilà on l'a fait déjà chez plusieurs
personnes ça se passe bien
voilà les chiffres des études vous voyez
que les effets indésirables
est ce que j'ai pu y jeter un coup
d'oeil il ya pas longtemps c'est les
mêmes que tous les
ce vaccin est très grave du tout et que
et qu'on n'y va quoi donc
donc on est on est plutôt bon sur les
objectifs je pense qu'on avant une
pertinence mais qu'après dans la
réalisation
là là on bloque alors sur les objectifs
on l'a compris le but c'était de
vacciner tous les gens dans les ehpad là
où il ya eu la plus forte mortalité
on s'était dit qu'on allait faire ça au
mois de janvier
ce serait lié aussi au nombre de doses
dont on dispose on en a pas à l'infini
donc il faut bien commencer par certains
enfin pendant tout le temps qu'on passe
si on passe trop longtemps à vacciner
les gens dans les ehpad
il ya tous les soignants de plus de 50
ans qui risquent leur peau alors on a
décidé qu'on allait un peu accéléré que
aussi allez avoir le droit de se
vacciner
et puis il ya aussi tous ceux qui ont
plus de 75 ans ou plus de 65 ans qui ne
sont pas dans des ehpad
il y en a beaucoup aussi ce serait
peut-être bien de les vacciner également
alors on a dit bon bain aussi vont avoir
le droit de se vacciner
enfin de se faire vacciner tout à coup
alors avant c'était au compte gouttes
maintenant c'est tout le monde va
pouvoir se faire vacciner en tout cas
tout ce que je viens de citer
ça fait beaucoup de monde d'un coup a
priori son n'aura pas assez de doses
soit on n'aura pas assez de gens soient
en aura pas assez de logistique mais on
va pas y arriver je pose la question à
jean françois qui a l'habitude de faire
des campagnes de vaccination un peu un
peu massive
oui enfin gea but des campagnes de
vaccination massives mais pas dans un
contexte de pénurie
deux vaccins tels que celui qu'on peut
vivre en france comme vous l'avez
rappelé en fait on démarre avec cinq
cent mille doses et puis c'est dans les
semaines qui viennent que chaque semaine
cinq cent mille doses s'ajouteront pour
pouvoir suivre un rythme soutenu de la
campagne de vaccination
donc on est à la fois sur une fois une
stratégie qui s'est fait en intégrant la
volonté de limiter les mortalités comme
je disais tout à l'heure limité aussi la
saturation des hôpitaux mais en
intégrant le fait qu'on avait que cinq
cent mille doses environ alors que dans
les épisodes c'est près de 2 des
dizaines de milliers de personnes qui
s'y trouvent et on a manifestement
négliger le fait qu' il y aurait des
doses qu'ils resteraient on va dire en
suspens parce que justement différentes
contraintes ont amené à une limitation
de capacité de développer rapidement la
vaccination en ehpad pour plein de
raisons sur lesquelles on pourra revenir
et ce qui a limité la possibilité de
développer aussi des vaccinodromes
notamment qui permettent une campagne de
vaccination de masse plus rapide et en
intégrant évidemment les médecins de
terrain et médecins généralistes qui
sont un très bon levier pour faire la
sensibilisation sur la question de la
logistique qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure
en fait on le voit bien depuis le début
de cette épidémie il ya mon point de vue
une dissociation importante entre des
moyens mis à l'hôpital en réanimation
une approche hospitalier au centre est
tout à fait légitime en période de crise
où il faut soigner des cas graves mais
on a négligé aussi et ça depuis
longtemps une activité de terrain avec
des moyens humains importants pour que
notamment le fameux tester tracé isolé
qui devait permettre de contenir
l'épidémie sur le terrain encore une
fois une épidémie
elle se gère en prenant à l'hôpital les
cas graves mais en la contenant sur le
terrain en identifiant les patients
positifs en les isolant dans de bonnes
conditions pour atténuer l'épidémie
on l'a pas fait parce que nous n'avons
pas cette expertise du terrain avec des
moyens des équipes qui vont chez les
personnes faire du test proposé des
moyens d'être isolé en hôtel ou ailleurs
dans de bonnes conditions
on n'a pas eu cette expertise et là on a
raté beaucoup de kloster intrafamiliaux
parce que des cas positifs revenez dans
leur famille contaminée
tout le monde donc cette difficulté on
va dire entre médecine curative médecine
préventive un certain élitisme à
l'hôpital et est négligent ce d'une
médecine de terrain aujourd'hui on la
paye cash
et d'un point de vue campagne de
vaccination est aujourd'hui mise en
tension du fait des carences en matière
de logistique on voit aussi que dans nos
approches dans nos manières de se
représenter la médecine les stratégies
vaccinales il faut certes des médecins
mais il faut aussi des logisticiens des
gens qui savent comment transportent des
vaccins comment on gère les flux
comment on gère les questions de
température alors le connais bien
lorsque l'on fait des campagnes de
vaccination en afrique subsaharienne
avec des températures importantes
on connaît tout ça depuis de nombreuses
années et ce set se déterminant là
manifestement n'a pas été intégré dans
la dent dans une task force qui qui
mériterait d'être beaucoup plus pro
active au niveau du gouvernement pour
que ces acteurs de la logistique et le
même niveau d'importance dans la
stratégie que les éminent virologue dont
on a besoin
mais qui sont pas utiles lorsqu'il
s'agit de transporter de mettre dans de
bonnes conditions
des vaccins qui doivent arriver au plus
proche des patients je vous interromps
jean-françois on fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après j'espère qu'on va
retrouver marie des vaccins qu'on a
perdu entre-temps c'est un problème
technique
[Musique]
dans quel état sont les indicateurs
aujourd'hui à quoi s'attendre l'année
prochaine ce sont là les différentes
questions qui vont nous occuper les pays
qui ont été les plus frappés les plus
touchés par les conséquences économiques
des maladies sont quatre pays européens
qui n'ont eu comme solution peu de
confiner l'économie le seul moyen qu'ils
aient jamais trouvée pour essayer de
régler les problèmes c'est la baisse la
seule chose c'est que évidemment on est
en train de détruire systématiquement
l'économie réelle ont beaucoup
d'entreprises confère fait ça c'est
clair les fonds propres ont été laminés
et donc la première priorité ce sera
dans l'étape galfond francs est ce que
finalement 2021 ce serait pas aussi
l'occasion de remettre un peu les
compteurs à zéro il faut bien se rendre
compte que 2021 ça va être purement en
tout cas sur les deux premiers
trimestres
une catastrophe
[Musique]
les chinois ne sont pas des guerriers ce
sont avant tout des commerçants ils ont
négocié avec quinze pays
le partenariat régional économie globale
qui crée la plus grande zone de libre
échange du monde
l'annnonce de sa signature par vidéo à
hanoi bouleverse les équilibres mondiaux
et consacre la perte d'influencé
américaine dans cette partie goût il est
clair qu'avec cet accord le pôle
économique mondiale tant au niveau du
développement que de l'interactivité est
dorénavant durablement installé sur le
continent asiatique avec son épicentre
en rendez vous compte un espace
économique occupé par 2 milliards 200
millions d'habitants qui représente 30%
de la production mondiale de richesse
il est triste et même inquiétant de
constater que l'europe se retrouve
aujourd'hui marginalisée par rapport à
l'air cep
[Musique]
vaccination qu'est ce qui cloche on
repense débat avec aurélie à roche qui
rédactrice en chef au journal
international de médecine avec françois
krakowski qui est médecin en santé
publique jean françois corty qui lui est
un médecin mais et ancien directeur des
opérations internationales de médecins
du monde et marie des vagues ce qu'on a
perdu qu'on espère retrouver bientôt
vous faites un signe dès qu'elle est là
continuons donc ce débat on ne
il ya quand même un certain nombre de
conseils en france on a beaucoup parlé
du conseil scientifique du conseil de
défense de tous les conseils d'un haut
conseil des conseils de ceux ci des
conseils de cela je crois même qu'on
vient d'en nommer à nouveau sur la
vaccination d'ailleurs
quand on nomme pas monsieur vaccin ou
d'un maquereau conseil de la vaccination
j'ai l'impression que le bilan est
catastrophique
après près d'un an maintenant d'épidémie
le bilan de leurs une autre organisation
est catastrophique on a pris du retard
constamment autant à peu près toutes les
étapes qu'elle quel regard portez-vous
là dessus aurélie à roche
on peut quand même dire que c'est très
difficile pour tous les gouvernements de
tous les pays même en allemagne qui
était montré comme un exemple maintenant
elle vit des moments difficiles c'est
une épidémie qui surprend tout le monde
une certaine forme d'orgueil de la part
des gouvernements de penser qu'ils vont
réussir à maîtriser une épidémie c'est
toujours très difficile occidentale ils
ont eu moins d'orgueil en asie par
exemple
oui c'est vrai c'est possible oui après
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'erreurs on peut pas le nier et il ya
eu beaucoup très souvent des défauts de
communication et ce qui est vraiment
dommageable parce que la communication
c'est plus facile il n'y a pas besoin
d'argent il n'y a pas besoin de
connaissances il ya juste besoin d'être
transparents honnêtes et aussi un peu de
d'essayer d'enthousiasmé les foules et
de leur dire ça va aller on va y arriver
on a par le discours sur la guerre qui
était presque trop pour le coup on n'a
pas eu vraiment le sentiment de d'un
gouvernement qui était auprès des
français qui allait on n'était pas
ensemble quoi on avait toujours
l'impression qu'ils et on nous
infantilise est qu'on vous ait pas ce
qu'il fallait enfin donc voilà ça
c'était je pense que c'était un des gros
défauts finalement le le bilan le plus
dur je trouve que c'est celui là plus
encore que sur la logistique parce que
finalement on finit toujours par se
rattraper aujourd'hui on est un des pays
qui fait le plus de tests on a ri quand
on compare avec la grande bretagne où
c'est très difficile de se faire tester
ou c'est pas gratuit bon voilà c'est
quand même remarquable en france on peut
plus se faire tester quand on veut ça
c'est très bien et je pense que sur la
vaccination va y arriver mais sur la
communication c'est vraiment regrettable
surtout que je pense que c'est parce
qu'il est plus difficile
françois krakowski tous ces comités
théodule donc nous sommes les champions
finalement je me demande si c'est à
écouter à vous écouter je demande si
c'est pas là pour la réflexion bien c
pour pallier un manque de quelque chose
j'écoutais monsieur cotisent je dire
c'est extrêmement intéressant en ce
qu'il dit je partage totalement son
analyse
là où on est en train de prendre un gros
retard en france est en fait la crise a
n'a fait quelque part que mettre en
exergue ce retard comprend en santé en
ce moment en france parce que pourquoi
on est tourné toujours uniquement voir
uniquement mais kazim kazim
majoritairement sur le soin le curatif
et énormément sur les hôpitaux on y en
ait un hôpital aux centristes mais c'est
tellement vrai il ya beaucoup plus
d'acteurs et ça a été du tout à l'heure
il faut il faut encore élargir pour la
santé c'est beaucoup plus globale que
juste le soin est aujourd'hui les
avancées en santé elles se feront
ailleurs qu'à l'hôpital les plus grosses
en tout cas on parle de prévention mais
aussi parlé de promotion de la santé
et ça tout ça ça a énormément manqué
dans la gestion de cette épidémie
que ce soit de rendre autonome les
personnes un peu plus avec leur santé
les c'est ce qu'on disait il on les perd
madame carole je le dis c'est on était
infantiliser c'est vrai il ya un
paternalisme énorme en santé en france
on n'arrive pas à sortir de ça et et
tous ces éléments là en fait c'est quoi
globalement et je dis pas ça parce que
c'est de mon domaine mais un petit peu
c'est la santé publique en france on est
on est pas on n'est pas une nation de
santé publique
et si tant qu'on ne viendra pas eh ben
on va continuer à prendre du retard par
rapport à d'autres pays
en tout cas on n'arrivera pas à voir des
avancées significatives en santé et donc
moi je mets un grand espoir et j'appelle
de tout mon coeur à ce que y est le
ségur de la santé publique qui était qui
était prévu qui a été un peu retardé
mais en tout cas j'espère qu'il sera
bien maintenue au printemps et qu'on
pourra avoir ce message pour avancer sur
la prévention la promotion de la santé
donnés notamment aux personnes la
possibilité d'être autonome vis-à-vis de
leur santé le pouvoir voilà prendre des
décisions sur des comportements qui sont
favorables ou non pour leur santé et de
savoir quoi faire s'il rend compte des
des événements sanitaire des symptômes
et c est tout ça ça implique de faire
rentrer dans les la création de
décisions soient aussi mais aussi dans
la mise en oeuvre d'autres d'autres
personnes qui sont pas médecins qui sont
pas soignants et en tout à l'heure il y
aurait plus besoin de logisticiens et je
pense que dans la dans la santé il faut
impliquer les entreprises les
collectivités locales
il faut impliquer l'éducation nationale
évidemment sur certains autres aspects
il faut élargir la santé et ça nous
aurait été d'un grand secours dans cette
crise
marie des vagues ce zay de retour et ce
que vous entendez bien marri devant pas
très bien
bon vous avez la parole donc du coup
j'ai pas trop suivi près d'am origine là
on en est à aux innombrables comités
théodule qui existent en france dans le
domaine de la santé
mais revenons un peu sur les les anti
vaccin puisque c'est de cela que vous
étiez en train de nous parler on dit que
il faut 60 % que 60% de la population
doit être vacciné pour qu'on espère
arrêter l'épidémie en tout cas que le le
virus cessent de circuler
donc là tout à coup tout le monde se
retourne vers les antilles vaccins en
dix ans mais est ce qu'ils vont nous
empêcher d'arriver à ces 60%
aurélie haroche disait que après tout
les vrais sortie vax les purs et durs en
france ne serait que 8 % que donc ils
sont pas si dangereux ça vous qu'est ce
que vous en pensez mais déjà acquis au
regard des dernières statistiques on les
a à peu près 45 % d'intentions de
vaccination donc cela fait quand même sa
campagne pour tendre de la population
française qui est pas vraiment faute
pour le faire et ensuite c'est vrai que
il y en a beaucoup qui sont prompts à se
laisser embobiner par les différentes
théories ça est ce qu'ils ne comprennent
pas le principe de ce vaccin qui pour
eux est comparable à de la thérapie
génique qui va leur injecter une puisse
changer enfin il ya pas mal de
deux théories farfelues sur ce vaccin et
qui sont trop âgés parfois sciemment et
qui sont crus par des gens qui n'ont pas
de daglan scientifique est ce que vous
pensez que c'est un vrai problème est ce
que ça va être un problème pour
atteindre ce qu'on appelle l'immunité
collective en france parce qu'on va
avoir un problème
aurélie à roche je ne sais pas on est
quand même des exemples de campagnes
vaccinales non sur lesquels on
s'inquiète et finalement qui se passe
bien par exemple la vaccination contre
la grippe cette année s'est très bien
passé on est souvent on a souvent des
pas des très bons taux de couverture de
vaccination contre la grippe et cette
année on a dit aux gens
le problème c'est que si tout le monde à
la grille que ça va vraiment sursaturé
les hôpitaux et les gens sont allés se
faire vacciner eux-mêmes de façon
presque un peu trop massif parce qu'il
ya eu des moments de pénurie et là on
peut être aussi sur un système pareil
parce que c'est un peu différent de se
prononcer dans un sondage et puis
finalement de réfléchir en son for
intérieur bon bah je vois que ma voisine
tout le monde s'est fait vacciner tout
le monde l'a bien peut-être que je
devrais y aller pour enlever mon masque
embrasser mes enfants quoi dans ce sens
que je pense qu'on pourrait l'atteindre
en ce sens ce n'est pas plus mal d'avoir
pris du retard parce qu'on regarde dans
les autres pays
oui c'est ça c'est là où il valide à
tour de bras comme il meurt pas comme
des mouches a priori on peut se dire que
ces rations oui ça c'est vrai que c'est
un des bombes font un être un petit peu
en retard
on a l'expérience jean françois corty
écoutez moi je suis pas je ne suis pas
inquiet sur sur l'impact des antilles
vaccin je dirais aujourd'hui c'est pas à
cause d'eux que cette tension et des
difficultés
un vacciner est ce que l'on sait
évidemment c'est que l' approche
communautaire les principes de
démocratie sanitaire qui implique
notamment que les élus que les médecins
terrain que même les patients contribuer
à une réflexion sur les stratégies cela
doit continuer à être respectés ou en
tout cas à valoriser pour justement créé
une créer une confiance qui qui qui est
mis en difficulté je voulais revenir sur
la sur votre question de précédentes par
rapport aux échecs aux attendus c'est
effectivement on a vu un début de
gestion de la crise un peu calamité en
terme de communication par le
gouvernement le président qui était sur
une sémantique
souvenez-vous très belliqueuse en
faisant on est en guerre
déjà ça commençait pas très bien dans la
mesure où effectivement enfin l'hôpital
les soignants sont en guerre mais pas
mais pas on va dire les civils
on ne prend pas des bombes sur la tête
comme en syrie ou au yémen
donc cette rhétorique belliqueuse mon
point de vue elle rend difficile et des
bas pascal mystifie une réalité elle
contribue à certaines manières d'édifier
les soignants et elle met de côté un
débat nécessaire permanent qui doit y
avoir entre un gouvernement un président
et ses terrains c est du terrain et sa
société civile dans un contexte où
encore une fois
la confiance doit être en permanence
entretenu donc on partait mal en termes
de communication et puis en termes de
capacité aussi d'assumer des
défaillances sur sur sur les masques et
est notamment
alors évidemment on est dans un contexte
aussi où depuis 15-20 ans à coûts
d'ajustement structurel ont détruit
progressivement les filets sociaux en
france notamment dans le cadre de
l'application d'une politique
ultralibérale conçoit un gouvernement de
droite ou de gauche qui met en tension
bien avant la crise du coc vide
le système de santé que ce soit à
l'hôpital ou sur le terrain avec je vous
le rappelle près de 30 à 40% de français
qui limite leurs soins dans un contexte
où 15% de la population française vit
sous le seuil de pauvreté
donc on est aussi dans un contexte où la
crise des masques ne date pas de mars
mais de bien avant ou voilà la politique
appliquée remet en question la
possibilité de capitaliser sur de
l'humain plutôt que aujourd'hui assumer
de devoir mettre des moyens donc on a un
gouvernement qui a fait des erreurs sur
un passif
de plusieurs années de destruction
progressive des filets sociaux et
un pilotage à vue qui est de mon point
de vue aurait été probablement fait par
de nombreux acteurs de droite comme de
gauche avec des conseils de spécialistes
qui se sont pas les politiques mais qui
influencent fortement les politiques ce
qu'on peut quand même dire on va dire
d'une certaine manière c'est que d'un
point de vue être social tout ce qui
relève du chômage partiel tout ce qui
relève des diamants pour les pour les
intermittents du spectacle artistes ou
autre si l'état social tel qu'il a été
développé aujourd'hui et les aides
telles qu'elles ont été promus n'avait
pas existé on serait dans un contexte
extrêmement difficile et donc il faut
garder en tête le fait que toutes ces
stratégies on va dire lié à un contexte
médecine de catastrophe avec le stade
ultime qui est le confinement qui peut
être reviendra chez nous on n'en sait
rien pour l'instant
finement total ne fonctionne que s'il y
a un état social maximum qui existe
aujourd'hui et là relativement tenu même
si on sait qu'il ya 1 millions de
précaires en plus en france et que une
crise sociale va s'accentuer et ce qui
veut dire encore plus de répartition des
richesses dans notre pays nécessaires si
on veut éviter un chaos social donc me
voilà moi je suis partagé je pense qu'il
ya des erreurs qui ont été faites je
pense qu'on n'a pas assez intégré les
sciences sociales dans la capacité de
pouvoir conduire une stratégie de lutte
contre l'épidémie et une stratégie
vaccinale tout ce qu'il apporte aurait
pu nous donner les sociologues et autres
anthropologues sur les stratégies de
défiance notamment des anti vaccins et
autres c'est des éléments qui sont
importants et puis ça
aussi c'est l'occasion de rappeler que
la recherche fondamentale la recherche
en sciences sociales est évidemment la
recherche médicale elle nécessite des
fonds supplémentaires
aujourd'hui et demain si on vous pouvoir
faire face à la crise actuelle et aux
maladies émergentes de demain c'est que
le début d'une succession probable de
crise difficile il va falloir un état
social beaucoup plus marquée en soi
crabe en ski mais c'est très intéressant
j'écoute avec grande attention ce qui
est monsieur corti en tout cas sur les
sur les sciences sociales je partage
aussi tout à fait bien et ça fait partie
de ce que je disais tout à l'heure sur
la l'importance de la santé publique au
sens très large et pas uniquement le
soin les sciences sociales ont toute
leur place si on envoie aujourd'hui le
l'importance sur le côté des aides
sociales
ça me fait aussi penser aux risques
économiques certes on sait aussi que la
santé l'état de santé est liée à l'état
économique d'un pays et donc sa capacité
aussi à répondre à tout cas elle faire
face sur le plan social la protection
sociale puisque les deux sont quand même
un petit peu lié est ce qu'on n'a pas su
faire
et ça c'est bien dommage c2c d'avoir
pour savoir où mettre le curseur dans
les dents les mesures de confinement
notamment c'est de pouvoir calculer pour
aider à la décision nous montrer les
conséquences économiques et donc sociale
que mène un contre un que produit d'un
confinement par rapport aux morts et aux
conséquences de la crise à dire que pour
trouver
voilà il ya sûrement des heurts qui ont
été faites enfin moi je suis j'aurais du
mal à juger parce que dans une situation
équipe comme celle là il ya forcément
des erreurs on en fait tous ses surnoms
des échecs ce qui est important c'est
des analyses et des corrigés
mais ce qui est dommage c'est que ben
allal je pense qu'il ya un enseignement
à avoir c'est de se dire il faut
investir sur ses capacités à donner des
éléments pour aider à la décision et
éviter les erreurs en tout cas bien
mettre les curseurs c'est à dire qu'est
ce qui est mieux c'est un peu c'est un
particulier comme réflexion mais c'est
de dire est ce que peut-être dans une
certaine mesure et vaut mieux un peu
plus de décès de moore aujourd'hui mais
éviter une catastrophe économique et
sociale dans cinq ans je dis pas que ce
sera le cas
un jeu insiste là-dessus mais en tout
cas on sait pas et on n'a pas su le
calcul est en tout cas et les montrer et
dire aux décideurs ben si vous confiné
trop longtemps ou au delà d'une certaine
période
les conséquences économiques et sociales
seront pires que les conséquences de la
crise aujourd'hui même si elles sont
plus visibles et ça aussi c'est des
éléments de santé publique donc tout ça
forme un tout et en tout cas j'espère
que comme on dit ben allal et s'il ya eu
des erreurs on l'est on les prendra bien
aux comptes et on s'améliorera pour les
prochaines crises sûr c'est sur ces
aspects là marie des valseuses
effectivement il ya pas mal il ya pas
mal de choses à prendre en compte
au delà du simple du simple problème de
la vaccination et je pense que ce qui va
falloir regagner avant tout c'est la
confiance des gens la confiance des gens
dont dans le gouvernement la confiance
des gens dans la science parce que ça te
faire et les gens ne sont plus en plus
tendance maintenant à écouter des gens
random sur internet que un scientifique
qui va parler ça c'est dommage
donc effectivement il va falloir
restaurer cette confiance alors après
comment s'y prend on ne va pas forcément
être évident
mais nous en tout cas de notre côté
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire
on ne fait pas que se moquer des
antilles daxon effet le seagate aurait
la confiance des gens en faisant de la
pédagogie
alors on est onze demandes beaucoup si
le fait qu'astra tombe de français veut
pas se faire vacciner ce va pas faire
que le virus va continuer de circuler
comme ça éternellement l' oms se posa
une question d'ailleurs se demande si ce
pas s'habituer à l'idée que ce vaccin
restent de manière permanente qui soit
endémique mais pas à lié au fait qu'il
ya des gens qui veulent pas se faire
vacciner 1 tout simplement que ce virus
pourrait rester de manière endémique
n'est ya aussi tous ceux qui n'ont pas
de vaccin aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas de
doses qui n'ont donc pas nos problèmes
de logistique notre lenteur à nous faire
vacciner
il ya tous les pays qui aujourd'hui
n'ont pas de vaccin leur disposition qui
sont des pays trop pauvre et ils sont
très nombreux
quels problèmes cela pose ça et pas
seulement pour eux parce qu'il ya des
morts mais sur l'ensemble de la planète
tant qu'il y aura des pays qui ne seront
pas vaccinés et combien de temps ça va
combien de temps ça va rester comme ça
vous avez des idées là tueur est liée à
roche
on pourrait être en fait déjà commencé à
constater que dans les pays les plus
pauvres l'épidémie est heureusement
moins forte donc et le virus circule
moins probablement pour des raisons
climatiques et en tout cas les décès
sont moins nombreux parce que c'est des
populations plus jeunes aussi
donc ça c'est entre guillemets positif
pour ces populations là mais c'est vrai
que la question de l'accès universel aux
vaccins même si emmanuel macron on avait
parlé au tout début est là elle est pas
du tout résolu et c'est un vrai problème
et c'est sûr que que ce soit l'union
européenne et encore moins les etats
unis 20 personne n'a essayé de mettre en
place un véritable système qui permette
un accès universel au vaccin mais c'est
vrai que en ce qui concerne les vaccins
aussi fire et modern a qui ont des
conditions de conservation très complexe
c'est visible mais il ya d'autres
vaccins qui vont arriver et qui sont
plus faciles à utiliser et qui
pourraient être utilisés dans les pays
voilà en
clients sur des organisations
humanitaires comme médecins du monde qui
ont tout à fait l'habitude mais en tout
cas la question de l'accès du prix elle
se poser elle n'a pas du tout été résolu
et c'est dommage
oui un mollet dessus j'en faisais encore
tiff oui on voit bien que le ce virus il
nous oblige nous oblige à une solidarité
nationale
on l'a vu un d'une région à l'autre même
si
l'épidémie est moins marquée que
l'incidence est moins marqué il faut
quand même se soutenir mutuellement
parce que si l'on ne traite pas une
région et bien c'est tout le pays entier
qui peut être peut être contaminée de la
même manière que cette ce virus nous
oblige à une sollicitude mondial pour
les raisons qui viennent d'être évoqués
g16 plomb négligent des pays voire des
continents entiers avec un virus qui se
propage wallon moins vite que dans les
pays du nord mais qui commence vraiment
à se répandre et bien ce virus reviendra
sous d'autres formes mutants ou autres
chez nous donc au delà d'une vision
solidaire que bien sûr je défends c'est
aussi un principe de santé publique que
d'avoir une couverture mondiale
aujourd'hui je pense à des pays comme le
brésil émergent qui sont dans une énorme
difficulté amérique latine le virus a
énormément tapait beaucoup de mortalité
aujourd'hui en afrique subsaharienne
pays comme le mali la république du
congo démocratique kangoo qui n'était
pas énormément tout jusqu'à présent
commence à avoir des incidences et des
nombres de cas très important avec des
systèmes de santé qui sont en tension
est très limité donc ce que l'on voit
évidemment c'est qu'aujourd'hui ce sont
les lois du marché
c'est pas nouveau et la solvabilité des
populations des états qui dicte
la distribution et l'achat des vaccins
aujourd'hui pratiquement aucun pays
africain ne fait partie du top 30 des
pays ont commencé à vacciner parce
qu'ils arrivent loin derrière on va dire
les pays dits riches donc 7,7
ce constat de mon point de vue nous
oblige à une une solidarité
pour limiter la casse dans les pays à
faibles ressources et aussi pour limiter
l'effet retour beaugrand qui pourrait y
avoir chez nous donc ces sollicitudes
elle s'impose plus que jamais en soi
grabovski et bajaur je partage tout à
fait l'avis sur la santé publique à un
moment si on ne peut pas juste voir la
santé surtout quand on parle d'une
épidémie mondiale aux portes de nos
frontières donc on qu' il peut y avoir
deux possibilités soit en effet une
solidarité des pays plus riches en tout
cas qui pourrait être financé des
campagnes vaccinales nord dans les pays
qui pourrait pas se le permettre
sinon une autre possibilité serait que
les entreprises et laboratoires qui
créent les vagues ça met à disposition à
la d2 suffisant pour qu'à participent ou
facilitent l'accès aux vaccins dans ces
pays je serais sûrement d'ailleurs un
moyen de rétablir la confiance je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas diminuer la
défiance envers renverser ses
entreprises et ses laboratoires
ça pourrait être pourquoi pas une
solution aussi aussi intéressante mari
pour revenir à cet aspect hiatus entre
les pays riches et les pays pauvres
l'empilage finalisme c'est d'abord un
problème effectivement de pays riches
mais effectivement la plus que plus que
jamais on a besoin d'une solidarité
entre tous pour que tout le monde puisse
avoir accès à ces vaccins et que l'on
puisse enfin terminé avec avec cette
situation qui vient vraiment intenable
et qui vient à plat pour tous parce que
ça commence effectivement atteindre
aussi les pays qui pour l'instant été
relativement épargnée
et commence à avoir là par exemple on
est une variante sud-africaine qui
commence à être bien sympa et c'est vrai
qu'il faudrait que tout le monde puisse
avoir accès à terme à ces vaccins soit
par comme le disait françois très bons
skis 1 comment une solidarité entre les
pays soit un geste des laboratoires
wyeth dupont battu pour aider à roche
un dernier mot il nous reste une minute
à on peut à l'espoir on espère que la
campagne de vaccination en france va
vraiment s'installer il est vraiment
démarré et que on va faire mentir la
défiance est que vraiment le
gouvernement va comprendre qu'il avait
eu tort d'avoir aussi peur de lui même
peut-être
voilà vous pensez qu'il ait eu peur oui
c'est vrai que c'est on a du mal à
l'imaginer mais mais effectivement la
peur est mauvaise conseillère
ça pourrait être l'explication je vous
remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis et bien
entendu je vous donne rendez-vous au
prochain numéro à mon avis on risque de
parler du coc vide encore pendant un
certain temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]